[Music]
you okay oh I'll be fine it's just my
ears you know
[Music]
I think I should skip Budapest - just go
straight to Paris I'm driving back now
may I make a suggestion
I'd take over that's very generous but
you sure it's ok with you
so let's pretend we don't know where
we're going or even who we are oh
brother driving in the only way to see a
country Colonel oh oh yes we are re I'm
driving to Paris with one of your dad's
business partners what up
in the house Paris I'm actually not
there yet Jack wanted to stop for the
night you what coltd don't forget
Frenchmen
are you happy we have a good marriage
that's what I asked you
are you happy the road rivers your
values are we ever going to enter Paris
there's an accident soon is it
no no place we're going to
[Music]
I thought me be in Paris by now
asteroids don't look busy let's make a
little teacher
well you and what have you done with my
American friend always in a hurry to get
to Paris
she's reason
he's something is
okay Jack it's straight to Paris now
right
I
I could remember what was by remembering
him your doctors